Wow, that is beautiful.
It's going to be a beautiful day.
Put that in your hat.
Jaques these guys are are beating us.
I didn't think they were this smart actually.
So close.
Blood scars.
Yeah look at that.
Look at that.
Here we go.
Wow, that is beautiful.
It's going to be a beautiful day.
Daniel here with DLM Men's Lifestyle
and today we're going hunting in South
Africa. I'm not going to do it alone.
I'm going to do it with Danie and Jaques
who are also part of the DLM team.
So the idea is to get them at the lodge.
Oh, here Danie is already.
Good morning.
This place is called Tzamenkomst and so
we're going to do this hunting trip with
a guide as well and we're all going to
meet up at the lodge for some breakfast.
It's a little bit chilly this morning huh.
Yeah but it's nice to be out in nature.
There's not a lot of people that's
sleeping over here which is nice.
Usually it's extremely busy because this
place is so popular right next to the river.
Oh, there he is.
Jaques, good morning.
Good morning.
It's go are you ready for this day?
I'm ready.
Ready to have some breakfast?
Yep, let's get to it.
Wow, beautiful.
Good morning, good morning.
How are you guys?
Good and you?
Good good.
Good.
Oh, there's a nice fire already.
Oh, that's the breakfast area.
Good.
Oh, it is cold this morning.
Jaques, I like those socks.
It looks familiar.
Let me let me do a closeup here.
I think it's the same as mine.
Check it out, check it out.
And what do you know?
Danie, you got the same.
What a coincidence.
Looks like we're a team.
Oooh, I'm going to start with the coffee.
And I brought my flask for the day as well.
Ooh these breads are awesome.
I think it's a Biltong bread.
Alright, I'm having a big breakfast
today because we're going to walk far.
And this is not the only thing I'm going to have.
We're also going to have some omelets.
Can I pray for us?
Thank you Father for this beautiful day.
Bless us today with the deer we need.
And thank you for the food.
In Jesus' name.
Amen.
Amen, amen.
Oooh, here we go.
That's the omelet.
Dankie dankie.
This is going to keep us full, huh.
The whole day.
We're going to walk after those deer and find
them - this will give us the energy we need.
Hey Peter.
Hello hello hello.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
So Peter, he's going to be our guide and
he's going to take us into the field.
It's pleasure to meet you and it will be great to
take you out.
Alright.
Thank you.
Let's do it.
So we stopped quickly because we're
going to shoot with a diagnosis and
after this we're going to go hunting.
But it's the first time that Danie and
Jaques are going to shoot an Impala.
So we just got to make sure we know
what we're doing.
How did that feel?
That was a self hit.
Oh you did.
Was too close.
Oh well, ready to get
on with it.
That's a gun.
Oh nice shot.
That's my square.
Yeah.
If that was a buck
it'll be down Danie.
Yeah, yeah.
So Jaques, you're next.
Wow, Jaques.
That's... my goodness.
Jeez..
I don't think...
I'm impressed with myself.
Why do I always have to go
after the best guy, I mean?
How was that Daniel?
Man it's good but I can't hear anything.
Danie ... Jaques... Me.
It's like the Three Musketeers.
I think we're ready to go hunting.
Yeah, let's go.
Wow, my goodness.
Yeah, this is a beautiful spot.
That's where we caught those Bass the other day.
But Peter, how's this going to work?
Stalk first and then hunt?
And then and try to get them?
We're going to watch over the fields
now and check where are they grazing.
And then we're going to move
in where they are and look
which ram you can take out. Okay, yeah alright.
And what deer do you have here on the farm?
We've got a few species from small Springbok,
Impalas, Nyalas, Sables, Golden Wildebeest,
Kudus, Elon, Gemsbok, Lechwe, Waterbuck, Giraffes.
Mountain Zebras - that's not the normal Zebra.
So we have quite a lot of species here and I
saw you got beautiful ones so it's not
just the Springbok but you have a White
Springbok and black one?
Basically the grand slam.
Right, grand slam.
Yeah and the Impalas also.
We have the black Impalas.
Okay, yeah so alright, yeah we have a big variety.
Yeah, but we're not going to go for those
today because we don't have that much money.
We'll go for the normal Impalas today,
So let's go and and stalk them and maybe...
maybe.. uh Danie first.
What do you say?
Yeah.
Now let's do it.
We saw some of them down there in those trees.
Now we just need to get down there.
So we see them right there.
In those trees.
We're going to go around and get them.
So Danie is walking closer to the guide
because he's going to shoot first.
And we're going to stay a little
bit behind but follow them.
The wind is not good at the moment because
I can feel it's pushing this way and they
are right there.
So if it just
turns a little bit they will smell us.
But you can see he's been walking here.
They're right behind those trees.
Right here.
It's a little bit difficult with this thick
bush here, so we're going to try to go around.
Excited.
Right there.
We're gaining ground but they're right over there.
Did you get it?
Don't think so.
And they're running past now
so that was the first shot.
This is spooky.
No they are a bit spooky.
It was not an easy shot so Danie
is not sure that he got it.
So we're just going to go to make sure I
haven't seen one that fell then got shot.
Alright so there's not one that fell.
Maybe if one is hit (wounded)
then we got to trail it.
Oh look, porcupine, Jaques.
You want it?
Put it in your hat?
Now we just need to see if we can see any blood.
So no blood found.
So Peter what are we going to do?
We're going to move around here -
check if they give us another chance.
And then we go move back to the vehicle.
And maybe move to other spot if they're
not going to give us another
chance because they are spooked.
Quite spooked now.
Yeah, okay they were spooked before we shot.
Right.
So we'll see.
So it's going to be a challenge
but we like challenges.
Alright, so we're just on the trail
now and you can see where they went.
That's a nice one.
Something killed this poor guy.
I think we lost them, yeah.
But I think we can check here,
near the bird hide.
Okay, maybe they went to that side.
Alright.
Otherwise we come back.
Just go to the vehicle.
Okay sounds good.
We're not exactly sure where
they are but we'll find them.
Man, those birds, when they make noise like that,
it feels like they're telling
the deer watch out, watch out.
Alright guys we changed the
location and we spotted them so
they are across this little hill here.
It's so warm we took our jackets off.
Danie.
And then
they're moving over there, the Impalas we saw
them running just behind these trees here.
So we're in the bush, and every
guy's got to do his thing.
Toilet number one.
Toilet number two.
Just listen to that quiet.
Look at this big grasshopper.
Where is it now?
Saw a minute ago.
There it is.
Look at that guy.
So there are a lot of different
pigs but this is an Aardvark hole.
So you can see it here.
There are many of them here on the farm.
And there's also water hogs.
So if we see one I really want to shoot one.
Going to make some nice cheese sausage.
Oh, there's another one.
Oh there are many.
There are many snakes here as well.
So always got to be careful where we put our feet.
I've been looking for snakes the whole time.
The Impala spotted us, so they just ran and now
we got to find some
again.
There.... there some Boks running there.
Too far away.
I should have put my other camera because
the quality of the GoPro is not that
good.
I don't see anything.
Nothing.
But I think they're behind this hill here.
They are right there.
He going to shoot the one on the left?
There's a ram there.
We're just waiting for the right time.
Yeah, now he's in with the mix there.
If they're that far away it gets a
little bit difficult and also the ram
is now in the middle of all the others.
So you can easily just accidentally
shoot some of the others.
So it's not what you want to do.
So we'll have to get closer again.
Oh, that was close Danie.
Yeah, let's go get him.
So what we're going to do now is
we're going to try to flank them.
Can see them there .... so we need to
go around just a little bit to the left.
There's a Kudu there as well,
but that's not our target today.
I think they spotted us so they're
running and checking us out.
You can see them there.
They are clever and they're a bit wild.
Jaques, these guys are beating us man.
Yep I didn't think they were this smart actually.
We saw some of them here in the bushes.
We're going after them.
They're here.
Jacques this is fresh, you can you can smell it.
Did you guys see it?
Right, right there.
I think he got him now.
We just need to see where they're going.
Yeah, that one's not feeling too good.
You can see him there.
That one he's going to fall soon.
Alright, I think we got to go and trail him.
Yeah, finally we got one huh after all this time.
I think we've been tracking these guys for
the whole morning.
The whole morning.
Nice.
Done.
When you do something like this
you appreciate animals a lot more.
Yeah, definitely compared to
just buying it from the store.
Danie
Yes, more personal.
Yeah.
Well done Danie.
Your first one.
Thanks.
Well done.
You see the thing
is a lot of people complain when they hear about
people going hunting but then those same people
go to the store and just buy their meat so
they just eat it but it's worse, you know,
because they pump those animals full of so much
unhealthy stuff just to get bigger and grow.
This is better.
You kill it yourself,
you know exactly where the meat comes from.
And then you appreciate it so much more.
So it is is actually a bit emotional.
But the problem is in this area,
if there are too many of them, then there's
not enough food for all of them as well.
Sicknesses can break out.
A lot of things .
But the first one is down.
We got two more to go.
Blood scars, yeah.
Has to be done.
So the easy part is hunting it.
But then when that's done you got to carry it.
So we're going to carry it
all the way to the truck.
It's just around the corner.
There it is... finally ... you ready?
Sorry... we should go for the smaller ones.
I think we just load it like this.
Alright we're going to quickly take
this back just do the necessary cuts,
take out the stomach, all those kind of stuff,
and then we have two more for me and for Jaques.
Danie, now your family has meat for a few months.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go.
Now the thing is when you're out of here
in the middle of Africa, I mean you get thirsty
and so this is the best thing that you can get.
The water stays cold for long.
I have to agree.
I have to agree, this is awesome.
Great to keep things cool.
Yeah.
So you see there in the distance is a Bergsebra.
Yeah, it's not a zebra.
Bergsebra.
And then on to the right you can see
the Wildebeest as well under the trees.
It's Jaque's turn.
They're running.
We want a ram but there's not a
ram so we need to look for others.
They're right in there but they know we are here
so we're actually just waiting
until they move out a little bit.
Man, they spotted us.
So they made a run for it.
Okay, I just realized when my alarm went off,
the Impala went to fetch my daughter from school.
It was the reminder.
I'm sorry Jacques.
So close.
Was so close.
I just want to show you there's
another one of these big ones.
Look at that.
There's a beautiful one here.
A beautiful Impala ram we saw and
Jaques might be able to shoot it.
It's right over there, the furthest end.
So we are just moving closer towards it.
I think you got it but it's I definitely hit
but I don't know where I hit it
So Jaques got it but he wounded
it and so we need to go after it.
So Jaques definitely got it
but it's here in the side.
So we got to shoot it again.
Can see us over there just
to the left of the Oryx.
Not steady on that shot,
so might have been in the rib somewhere.
Let's go see.
Alright, Jaques got his Impala.
How do you feel Jaques?
It feels good.
I wish I just shot it with one shot
but still the job is done, right?
Yeah, congratulations.
Dankie.
First one, your first one.
Yeah thank you for your life.
Yeah, with hunting, with your first kill.
This is a must.
Need some blood on your face
to appreciate the animal.
There you go.
First one.
There we go.
Jaques finally got his.
Now we're going to go back.
We're going to have some
lunch and then I got to do mine.
I feel a little bit emotional about
it because it's not easy to see this right?
But I don't want to support really any more
companies who just make animals fat - pump them
full of hormones - and then you have to eat it.
This is a lot better.
It's just you get your hands dirty yourself
instead of letting other people do it for you.
And you appreciate it a lot more.
This is a Bontebok.
Bontebok is what we call them - those
lines are so defined - beautiful - but it's
not our target today so we can't shoot them.
Now the idea is to work the meat as
soon as possible before it goes bad.
And you guys - do you speak
English or only Africans?
Africans... okay okay so just
to explain, this is Niku.
He's the expert.
He's helping us because
we don't have a lot of time.
I also need to go shoot mine.
But he's the expert so he's
just busy here butchering.
And yeah he's speaking Africans.
That's our first language.
Because it's their first deer, right?
They need to eat either the balls because
it's a ram or they can choose the liver.
So Jaques what do you choose?
Liver. And it needs to be raw.
Danie what do you choose?
Liver or .... I don't think
I shoot ... I didn't shoot this.
But you got to choose which one.
I know, give me give me a second to decide.
The choice is difficult.
They have to decide and also you
see the blood on Jaques's face.
Yep, that's what needs to be happening.
And then there is a small piece I must give you.
A bigger piece.
Okay okay the rule is
you must chew it before you swallow okay, so
you can't just swallow the whole thing, okay?
You must chew a little bit, okay?
Not swallow.
You must chew it and then swallow .
Oh that's disgusting.
It's like sushi.
It's not fish.
Well done
well done.
The next up is Danie's Impala.
There he goes.
So Danie you know what this means.
I forgot something in the car.
It means we were busy with
your buck so you're got to eat.
Deliver now.
Just think it's sushi.
Little bit of fish. Sashimi. Bush fishes.
You only have to do it once Danie,
The second time you don't have to do it again.
It's the first one - that's why you have to do it.
You swallowed the whole thing.
You didn't even chew.
I did - I chewed two two times.
Twice.
I'm done.
Alright guys, Nico is going
to finish up for us here.
The sun is almost setting so we need to go just to
have enough time so that I can shoot mine as well.
Wildebeest.
There they go.
You can see the little bit different from
the normal Wildebeest because they have this
golden color.
Beautiful.
Alright so we're back in the field
and I'm thinking about shooting a
Springbok so we can show you guys
what our national deer looks like.
We're using this little bush here as cover behind
it but they're really far.
We might take the chance.
Tried to stalk them but man they're too smart.
They're gone.
So I got to try to find some other ones.
There is a Lechwe bull.
That's exactly what we need ... the Springboks.
There's one ram standing there but we're not
allowed to shoot from the car because they
do some wild rides here... Safari drives every
now and then and they need them to be okay with
people in the car but they're not afraid.
But the moment we're going to get out.
He's going to run.
There is already...
moving ... there are a few Springboks here but we
can't shoot them because they're the white ones.
They're more special so we're going to
try to find a nice one but not these.
So we couldn't get the Springboks... they're too
wild... but we're seeing some Impalas. Right over
there... and they've already seen us.
So we're going to try to go around.
We're going to get closer.
They're far over there.
So we're chasing these Impalas but every
time where we just want to shoot them,
they see us and they move and you
can't shoot them like that so now
again they saw us and they went
over the hill so we're chasing.
Alright so it was a very
very far shot but I got him.
But I think his leg got the worst of it.
It's not what we want so we need to go
and try to kill him as soon as we can.
I think .. I think we got him now.
Alright guys, we know now for sure he's done.
He's over there.
My first Impala.
There he is.
It feels sad you know.
There we go.
Thank you for your life.
It's not easy taking a life
but yeah it's going to feed us for a
month or so... so let's get him home.
Thank you Peter.
Pleasure.
I hope you enjoyed your hunt ...
all three of you .. yeah good.
See forward to a happy year again.
We will come again definitely.
Peter you made it special.
Made it amazing.
I say it in English but it's Peter
that's how you said it correctly.
Thank you so much.
Oh let's go guys.
So we walked really far for this guy.
We're carrying him now.
Danie and Jaques, they're helping me.
There we go.
That's the one thing and we got to probably
carry this how many meters do you think?
He said two km.
Let's do it.
Yeah, this one was quite far.
This is Luke guys .. so Luke,
it's because of him that that we could have
gone out and shot these amazing things.
And then also Peter.
Thank you guys so much
and then, man, it goes so fast.
These two are already done.
Yeah, quick.
It's the professional hands
but Luke they haven't eaten liver yet.
Because he hasn't shot before.
Are you sure?
We're not too sure Luke.
Yeah, let's watch because we have proof
of these two yeah so so next time and
next time so we got some group pressure
here so what you do a group pressure you
say no but in this case because they're
my friends, I will say yes a small piece.
The rules are if you've never hunted before - if
you shoot your buck - you need to eat that liver.
Doesn't sound that good now.
But I'll I'll eat a small piece guys.
Yeah, alright, so now next time when we ask you
if you've done it then you've got video proof.
You can trust my word.
I'm a Christian.
I'm a reborn believer.
My word is my bond.
So I'm asking Niku here if he wants to eat a
little piece with me and also the kids over there.
It's not good.
Yes now we believe you.
Now we need coffee or something.
That was terrible.
Guys, it's getting late here so what we going
to do is we're going to prepare the meat and
then oh man I still have this.
I don't want to speak because I
want to throw up.
Why you laughing.
So we're going to finish up here with
the meat and I'll show in another day
what it looks like, when we sit down
and have some dinner maybe with Nikita.
Hey guys we're back home.
This is all the meat.
We have enough here for the next few months.
This is almost halfway full.
We're going to take some of them.
We're going to work them.
We're going to make some Biltong which
we here in South Africa call beef jerky.
Biltong.
But it's just a lot better and nicer.
And right now we're going to
have a barbecue just to taste it.
The fire is going and while that's
going we're going to prepare the food.
Alright guys, check this out.
So this is the Impala meat.
We call it a Rooibok here in South Africa.
But this is the guy we're going to use
to make some steak for me, for Jaques,
for Nikita as well and then we have some
leftovers because Jaques and I - we're hitting
the gym and so this is really good protein.
But I'm going to make a nice sauce here for it.
First of all, some olive oil.
So this is the sauce that I'm
going to make and we're going to put it on the
beef and we're going to put it on with this guy.
Next up, we got some thyme. I like to get
the natural one because it's just so much
better.
Next up we have some garlic.
Ooooh you cannot do without any garlic.
Oh we going to put a lot a little bit
more ...woo.... nice... and then
I'm just going to add some salt.
Oooh I'm ready for this guy.
Bad breath combo.
Yeah, exactly.
Look at that - you can
get - that's lean not a lot of fat.
And very important, no hormones.
So good.
Cool.
They are ready.
Here we go.
So this is the traditional braai broodjie.
So what we do - we just use for now whole wheat.
You can use any bread but we're going
to add some butter there not too much.
We're going to try to keep it
healthy but a loves her butter.
So we can to add it there and
then these are the ingredients.
So first up, tomatoes that goes on .
Some onions.
Now Jaques of course, he cut
everything into pieces for me.
The traditional way is... it's got to be round.
But Jaques, did you cut this in pieces?
So Daniel wanted thin slices um because he's
a picky eater so I figured I might as well
just chop it up so then he can't
complain about it being not thin.
Okay, it's all good.
So then we add the onions,
there we go, and then... cheese.
Now the thing is, when I grew up,
we were five kids, right?
So my mom would add cheese
just like that - just a little bit you know?
To save money but since this has been a special
trip and says it is a very special time
because we went, we stalked, we hunted,
our first Impalas, we're going to make this
for Nikita, we're going to make it special.
So this is how much cheese I'm going to add.
More cheese - more and more that
is the traditional Braai broodjie.
But, what I'm going to do because I know
Jaques you love this as well - chili.
Jalapenos.
There we go.
We're going to add some jalapenos.
Now all we do we put this on like that.
And then that's going to go on the barbecue.
Always use the onion just to
kill the germs and make it clean.
Jaques, we getting closer.
We almost ready.
Yeah.
Okay guys, we're going to put
it on, and then when we turn it around we're
going to start putting on our special sauce.
That is done.
Ah, it's hot.
Look at all that garlic.
Oh it's going to be good.
Check this out.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Hey
I'm smelling something delicious.
Yeah here you are, finally my queen.
Are you hungry?
Oh man, I've been hungry for the last hour cuz
I've been smelling these, like a good food.
So Nikita is very specific.
She likes her meat medium rare.
Yes.
Yes please.
Not pressure.
It's almost ready.
You can sit down.
Medium rare with a bit of love.
Okay sounds good.
Here we go.
This is the moment.
It's the moment of truth.
Medium rare.
Let me check, let me check.
Is it medium rare?
Medium?
Bit more medium?
Wait look, give the plate back.
Wait wait wait, bit more medium.
Stop the recording.
But I think it's still going to be good.
We want food.
Thank you.
Okay let's check this one.
Sorry I'm in your face but yeah,
should be a bit more medium rare.
Yeah, next time.
Next time.
Give it a taste.
I think it's still going to be good.
Yeah is it.
Enough salt?
Is enough salt?
Definitely enough salt.
Guys, do you mind if we just quickly pray?
Yeah, yeah sure.
Let's do it.
Jacques would you? Would you pray for..?
I'll pray for us.
Right.
Lord I want to thank you for this amazing
opportunity to be able to to get this good meat -
this lean meat Lord - on in the right way as well
- but I want to thank you that we can share this
moment and just enjoy this wonderful food Lord.
I want to pray in your name.
Amen.
Let's eat.
Here we go.
What does Impala taste like?
Good, yeah, I want more.
Nice.
Alright,
there we go.
There we go.
This is what we call Braai broodjies.
All right, nice.
I'm going to add the cheese.
I do want the all one.
Which one do you want?
One with the most cheese?
Can I take it with my hand?
You can.
How was the hunting?
Very good.
Guys, it's been an amazing time so far.
Now we are plucking the fruits of our labor
and it looks like Nikita is enjoying it.
And Jaques is enjoying it as well.
Jaques?
Very good.
So guys this is the end of the video.
Please subscribe if you haven't done so already.
We bring out videos every Friday.
Everything has got to do with men
so we'll see you in the next video.
Bye.